GO CHECK IT OUT.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE A MEAN MAN,
SEAN.
>> Sean: JUST HONEST, WE TELL
THE TRUTH HERE.
WELCOME TO A "HANNITY."
IT IS IMPEACHMENT EVE.
THE IS COMING TO TOWN, AND WE
ARE JUST NOW HOURS AWAY FROM THE
CORRUPT, COMPROMISED, COWARD,
CONGENITAL LIAR ADAM SCHIFF SHOW
ON CAPITOL HILL.
BROUGHT TO YOU BY HIM AND HIS
FELLOW RATING PSYCHOTIC
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR TOP ALLIES
IN THE MEDIA MOB.
FIRST, THOUGH, THIS.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
EVERYTHING YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
THE NEXT 22 WEEKS IS RIGGED.
THIS IS A PHONY SHOW TRIAL.
THERE IS ZERO DUE PROCESS, NONE.
IT IS YET ANOTHER FRAUDULENT
HOAX, CONSPIRACY THEORY.
IT IS ANOTHER WITCH HUNT.
IT IS WROUGHT WITH RAMPANT, I
MEAN RAMPANT, PUTRID HYPOCRISY.
A REPULSIVE DOUBLE STANDARD.
BY THE WAY, IT'S ALL BAD FOR THE
COUNTRY, BUT THIS IS WHAT YOUR
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY HAS
BECOME.
THIS IS WHO THEY ARE.
THIS IS WHAT DEFINES THEM,
FRANKLY, PERFECTLY.
REMEMBER, TOMORROW THERE IS NOT
ONE SINGLE THING THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE DONE -- NOT ONE -- THE PAST
THREE YEARS.
NOT A SINGLE THING.
THEY HAVE DONE, EXCEPT FOR TRY
TO HURT DONALD TRUMP, AND WE,
THE PEOPLE, THAT SUPPORT HIM,
THAT SHOP AT WALMART PROUDLY AND
BELIEVE IN GOD.
THEY HAVE NOT LIFTED ONE FINGER
FOR A BETTER ECONOMY, TO CREATE
ANY JOBS, OR IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF YOU, WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE DONE ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO MAKE THIS COUNTRY
SAFE AND SECURE.
INSTEAD, THEY HAVE SPENT THE
LAST 34 MONTHS SLANDER, SMEARS,
THIS MANAGEMENT OF THE
PRESIDENT, WITH ONE COORDINATED,
POLITICAL HIT JOB AFTER ANOTHER.
YOU KNOW, THE ROUTINE.
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA, STORMY,
STORMY, STORMY, NOW UKRAINE,
UKRAINE, UKRAINE.
SAME PEOPLE, SAME LIARS, SAME
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS.
LEFT, FRANKLY, THEY NEVER
ACCEPTED THE RESULTS OF
THE 2016 ELECTION.
THEY THOUGHT TRUMP WAS GOING
DOWN IN FLAMES.
WE HAVE SHOWN YOU THE TAPE.
THEY WERE LAUGHING.
THEY WERE MOCKING.
THEY WERE RIDICULING.
THEY NEVER SAW THIS COMING.
THEY WERE BLINDSIDED BECAUSE, IN
ALL REALITY, DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
WILLING ACCOMPLICES IN THE MOB
AND THE MEDIA, THEY LIVE IN THIS
ONE BUBBLE.
THEY HAVE ONE AGENDA, ONE SET OF
OPINIONS.
YOU'VE GOT THE DEMOCRATS, THE
MOB, JOINED TOGETHER IN WHAT IS
A SICK, UGLY, DEGENERATE LEFT
WING SOCIALIST, UNHOLY ALLIANCE.
AND REMEMBER THIS, THEY THINK
THEY ARE SMARTER THAN YOU ARE,
AND THEN WE ARE, WE COME OF THE
COME OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY THINK THEY KNOW BETTER THAN
US.
THEY HAVE UTTER CONTEMPT -- AND
THEY SHOW IT, IT COMES OUT AND A
LOT OF WAYS, FOR US, THAT ARE
SMELLY WALMART SHOPPERS.
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
UNDERSTANDS THIS.
THIS IS A SERIOUS PART.
THEY HATE EVERYTHING AND
EVERYONE HE IS REPRESENTING.
THEY HATE THE CROWDS THAT SHOW
UP IN MASSIVE NUMBERS TO SUPPORT
HIM.
THEY REFERRED TO US NOT ONLY AS
SMELLY WALMART PEOPLE,
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES, ANGRY,
BITTER AMERICANS THAT CLING TO
GOD, OUR SECOND AMENDMENT, OUR
BIBLES, AND RELIGION.
GUILTY AS CHARGED.
AND BY THE WAY, FOR YEARS, THEY
JUST BELIEVE THE MUELLER REPORT
WAS THERE HOLY GRAIL.
THEY FOUGHT HIS FINDINGS WOULD
UNDO THE RESULTS OF THE
ELECTION.
THEY NEVER THOUGHT THEY WOULD
LOSE.
THEY BELIEVE MUELLER HAD HIM,
THEY WERE WRONG.
NO COLLUSION, NO CONSPIRACY, NO
OBSTRUCTION.
SO NOW THEY ARE ONTO PLAN B, C,
D, AND THEY ARE OUT FOR BLOOD,
MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT.
THE NEXT 357 DAYS, IT IS
PERFECTLY OBVIOUS -- NOW, YOU'VE
GOT TO UNDERSTAND, TO BE A
DEMOCRAT, OR PART OF THE MEDIA
MOB, YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO BE
WILLING TO ENGAGE IN WHAT IS
ONLY A SHOCKING LEVEL OF RAW
HYPOCRISY THAT DEFIES ALL
INTERFERENCE OF LOGIC,
INTELLECT, REASON, AND COMMON
SENSE.
IN OTHER WORDS, TO BE A DEMOCRAT
OR IN THE MEDIA MOB, YOU HAVE TO
BELIEVE THAT RUSSIA COLLUSION IS
SUCH A NATIONAL CRISIS THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO SPEND TWO AND
HALF YEARS INVESTIGATING A HOAX
ABOUT TRUMP AND RUSSIA.
BIT AT THE SAME TIME, YOU HAVE
TO COMPLETELY IGNORE
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAI
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAD
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAF
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAR
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PA,
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAD
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAR
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAY
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAS
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAI
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAN
DOSSIER.
THAT'S HOW BITTERLY, SICK,
TWISTED, AND PARTISAN -- AND
HYPOCRITICAL -- YOU NEED TO
BE.
YOU HAVE TO OBSESS ABOUT PHANTOM
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE CHARGES
IN THE MUELLER REPORT, BUT THEN
TOTALLY IGNORE SUBPOENAED EMAILS
THAT WERE WERE DESTROYED,
DELETED WITH BLEACH BID AND
SMASHED WITH HAMMERS, WITH
DEVICES.
YOU HAVE TO SPEND YEARS
OBSESSING ABOUT THE HORRORS OF
FOREIGN ELECTION INTERFERENCE,
BUT THEN JUST LOOK THE OTHER
WAY, LIKE IT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
WHEN A DNC OPERATIVE, WE NOW
KNOW ACTUALLY COLLUDED WITH THE
GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE IN ORDER
TO SMEAR TRUMP, AND MANAFORT,
ALL WHILE BOLSTERING THE
CAMPAIGN OF HILLARY CLINTON IN
2016.
ALL OF THIS HAPPENED.
TO BE A DEMOCRAT, TO BE A MEMBER
OF THE MEDIA MOB, YOU HAVE TO
DEMAND FAIRNESS AND ELECTIONS,
BUT THEN IGNORE HER DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY WAS ACTUALLY RIGGED
AGAINST BERNIE SANDERS.
YOU HAVE TO DRAG
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH, HIS WIFE AND
YOUNG KIDS, THROUGH THE MUD.
WITH NOTHING BUT BASELESS
ACCUSATIONS PUSHED BY A BUNCH OF
"I BELIEVERS" I DON'T BELIEVE IN
DUE PROCESS, THEY DON'T BELIEVE
IN THE PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE,
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND, YOU HAVE
TO IGNORE WHAT ARE SERIOUS RAPE,
SEXUAL ASSAULT ALLEGATION
AGAINST LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF
VIRGINIA.
IN THAT CASE, THERE WERE NO "I
BELIEVERS."
TO BE IN THE MOB AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, YOU HAVE TO
CALL EVERYONE WHO RUNS FOR
OFFICE RACIST, SEXIST,
HOMOPHOBIC, THEY MUST KNOW MY
XENOPHOBIC, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH,
BUT WHAT MIKE LET RALPH "KKK"
NORTH HIM OFF THE HOOK.
YOU ALSO HAVE TO ACCEPT, FIRST,
DELIVER THE BABY, THEN MAKE THE
BABY COMFORTABLE, THEN LET THE
MOTHER DECIDE IF THE BABY LIVES
OR DIES.
YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE IN OPEN
BORDERS.
AND YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE IT IS A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS, 90% OF THE
HEROIN COMING ACROSS OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
YOU HAVE TO BE WILLING TO
ORGANIZE A WOMEN'S MARCH, A
SO-CALLED EQUAL RIGHTS, AND THEN
APPOINT AN ANTI-SEMITIC
BIGOT THAT SUPPORTS SHARIA LAW
TO LEAD THE MOVEMENT, AND THEN
SAY WITH A STRAIGHT FACE YOU
CARE ABOUT WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
TO BELIEVE IN THIS REPULSIVE --
WHAT IS REALLY AN ELITIST,
HOLIER-THAN-THOU MOB, YOU HAVE
TO PROCLAIM THAT THE IDENTITY OF
THE BRAVE, FAKE, PHONY,
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER, HEARSAY WITH
SOME HOMEWORK, THAT PERSON MUST
BE HIDDEN.
THAT'S A HEARSAY COMPLAIN ABOUT
THE UKRAINE CALL, THAT PERSON
NEEDS TO BE ASKED
RESPECTED, BUT THEN BE TOTALLY
OKAY WHEN CBS FIRES A NEWS
PRODUCER FOR HELPING BLOW THE
WHISTLE ON A STORY THAT
"ABC NEWS" SPIKED IN 2015 ABOUT
A CONVICTED PEDOPHILE, JEFFREY
EPSTEIN.
WRIGHT, HUMPTY DUMPED A?
RIGHT MIKE WRIGHT, JEFF ZUCKER?
AND PERHAPS THE MOST SHAMELESS
HYPOCRISY OF ALL, YOU HAVE THIS
CORRUPT, COMPROMISED COWARD, FOR
THREE YEARS, NOTHING BUT A
CONGENITAL BUYER -- BY THE WAY,
LIGHT IN THIS CASE ALREADY.
ADAM SCHIFF IS GOING TO KICK OFF
THIS PUBLIC WHICH TRIAL INTO
WHETHER OR NOT PRESIDENT TRUMP
ENGAGED IN A QUID PRO QUO --
WAIT A MINUTE, WILLING TO CHANGE
THAT.
X THAT I WOULD, NOW WE WILL CALL
IT EXTORTION, WITH THE COUNTRY
OF UKRAINE.
OF COURSE, HE IS ALLEGING THE
TRACK KNOW MY PRESIDENT TRADED
U.S. AID IN EXCHANGE FOR UKRAINE
COOPERATION IN ELECTION
INTERFERENCE AND INVESTIGATION.
THE INTERESTING THING IS, NOT
ONE TIME -- DO YOU KNOW, NOT
CALL, NOT ONCE, IN THAT PHONE
CALL HIM, NOT SINGLE TIME, DID
THEY EVER BRING UP THE ISSUE OF
AID.
NOT ONCE.
AND THEN THEY IGNORE
COMPLETELY -- AGAIN, ONLY A
DEMOCRAT CAN DO THIS, ONLY THE
MOB CAN DO THIS -- A CORRUPT
INVESTIGATION INTO
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
AND HIS SON, HUNTER.
DEMOCRATS WANT YOU TO FORGET
THREE THINGS.
ONE, THE UNITED STATES HAS A
COOPERATION AGREEMENT WITH
UKRAINE TO INVESTIGATE CRIMES.
ELECTION INTERFERENCE IS A
CRIME.
USING TAXPAYER DOLLARS, QUID PRO
QUO JOE, YOU GET THE BILLION,
YOU FIRE THE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING MY SON.
THAT'S PROBABLY ILLEGAL, TOO.
AND THE PRESIDENT, THERE ALSO
FOR FORGETTING THIS -- NUMBER
TWO.
HE HAS A SWORN DUTY TO UPHOLD
THE LAWS OF THE LAND.
NUMBER THREE, THERE IS CLEAR
EVIDENCE OF POTENTIAL CRIMES.
WHEN IT COMES TO INTERFERENCE,
WE KNOW "POLITICO" DETAILED HOW
THE COUNTRY OF UKRAINE WAS
ACTIVELY WORKING TO ELECT
HILLARY CLINTON, COORDINATING
WITH THE DNC OPERATIVE WHO MET
WITH THEM AT THE UKRAINIAN
EMBASSY IN WASHINGTON.
AND WHEN -- BY THE WAY, ALSO A
UKRAINE COURT CONFIRMED ALL OF
THIS.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO CREEPY,
CRAZY JOE 30330, WE ACTUALLY
HAVE VIDEO EVIDENCE OF A REAL
QUID PRO QUO.
AND HIM BRAGGING ABOUT IT.
IT JUST SO HAPPENS TO BE WITH
THE COUNTRY OF UKRAINE.
JOE, YES, THREATENED TO WITHHOLD
$1 BILLION IF THE UKRAINIAN
PROSECUTOR WASN'T FIRED WITHIN
SIX HOURS.
NOW, ASK YOURSELF THIS QUESTION
TONIGHT: WHY WOULD A SITTING
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES CARE ABOUT SOME
DOPEY PROSECUTOR IN UKRAINE?
WELL, I THINK WE KNOW THE
ANSWER, IT PROBABLY HAD
SOMETHING TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN,
REMEMBER, HE WAS TOLD BY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND OTHERS
THAT THIS PROSECUTOR WAS
INVESTIGATING HIS SON ON A
HUNTER.
NOT A KID COME HE'S LIKE 49
YEARS OLD.
ZERO EXPERIENCE, HUNTER BIDEN.
HE WAS GETTING PAID MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM UKRAINE
AND GAS ENERGY GIANT, BURISMA
HOLDINGS.
AT THE SAME TIME HIS FATHER WAS
IN CHARGE OF U.S.-UKRAINIAN
RELATIONS FOR THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
NOW, HUNTER MUST HAVE OFFERED
GREAT EXPERIENCE IN UKRAINE.
NO.
ENERGY?
NOPE.
OIL?
'S NON.
GAS?
NON.
A QUID PRO QUO JOE WANTS YOU TO
BELIEVE THERE IS ZERO EVIDENCE
OF ANY POTENTIAL WRONGDOING.
WHAT YOU ARE ABOUT TO SEE IS A
LIVE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LOOK, I THINK EVERY SINGLE,
SOLITARY, SERIOUS INVESTIGATOR,
INCLUDING YOUR NETWORK AND
OTHERS, HAVE LOOKED AT THIS,
HAVE SAID THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
ZERO BASIS TO THE ACCUSATION
THAT I ACTED ANYWAY
INAPPROPRIATELY, OR THAT MY SON
DID.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT TRUMP TRYING
TO CREATE A DIVERSION.
>> Sean: WHAT JOE BIDEN SAID
RIGHT THERE IS A LIVE.
HE IS THE ONLY CORRUPT PLAYER
THAT WE KNOW WITH UKRAINE.
SO HE WOULD PREFER YOU DON'T
BELIEVE HIS OWN BRAGGING VIDEO
EVIDENCE, AND DON'T BELIEVE THAT
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER BIDEN'S
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR PAYDAY WITH
UKRAINE ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
WE'VE DETAILED, THANKS TO
GREGG JARRETT, THAT THE BIDENS,
ESPECIALLY JOE, PROBABLY IS IN
REAL LEGAL TROUBLE, IF WE HAD
EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS IN
THIS COUNTRY, AND EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LAW CALLED THE
FOREIGN CORRUPT PRACTICES ACT,
WHERE IT IS ILLEGAL, JOE, FOR A
U.S. PERSON TO COERCE OR
INFLUENCE FOREIGN NATION INTO
TAKING ACTION -- BY THE
PROSECUTOR -- THAT MIGHT
FINANCIALLY BENEFIT THAT PERSON,
HIS FAMILY -- HUNTER -- OR
BUSINESS.
AND THEN WE HAVE BRIBERY LAWS
WHERE IT IS ILLEGAL TO OFFER OR
PROMISE ANYTHING OF VALUE -- A
BILLION DOLLARS -- FOR A PUBLIC
OFFICIAL TO INFLUENCE AN
OFFICIAL ACT -- FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR.
AND BY THE WAY, GIVE AID
OFFERING PROMISING ANYTHING OF
VALUE TO A PUBLIC OFFICIAL IN
EXCHANGE FOR AND OFFICIAL ACT AS
A VIOLATION OF THE GRATUITY
STATUTE, ALSO A FELONY.
THAN THE HOBBS ACT, A THREAT TO
A FOREIGN OFFICIAL IN ORDER TO
OBTAIN AN OFFICIAL, AFFECTING
FOREIGN COMMERCE, CONSTITUTES
SOMETHING CALLED EXTORTION.
DEMOCRATS TONIGHT ARE HOPING
YOU, WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
SMELLY WALMART TRUMP
SUPPORTER'S, THEY IGNORE WHAT
OUR INESCAPABLE TRUTH ABOUT
FIGHTING CORRUPTION.
INSTEAD, WHAT THEY WANT YOU TO
BELIEVE IS THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
GUILTY OF THE QUID PRO QUO.
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE OPINIONS
OF PEOPLE THAT SHARED THEIR
HATRED OF DONALD TRUMP.
THE DEEP STATE BUREAUCRATS,
ABOUT A PHONE CALL AND THEIR
BIASED INTERPRETATION OF A CALL
FOR WHICH A TRANSCRIPT HAS NOW
TOTALLY PUBLIC FOR ALL TO SEE.
THEIR INTERPRETATION IS DEAD
WRONG.
THERE IS NEVER ANY MENTION OF
ANY FINANCIAL ANYTHING IN THAT
PHONE CALL.
AND GET THIS: WE HAVE A NEW YORK
POST ARTICLE WRITTEN BY JONATHAN
TOBIN, HE BRINGS UP A REALLY
GOOD POINT.
"HOW CAN THE HOUSE EXAMINE THIS
THIS MANNER WITHOUT PROBING
TRUMP'S MOTIVATION FOR
REQUESTING UKRAINE INVESTIGATE
THE BIDENS"
THE BIDENS."
BUT DON'T EXPECT TO SEE HUNTER
OR JOE BIDEN TESTIFIED.
THE COWARDLY, CORRUPT,
COMPROMISED, CONGENITAL LIAR
SCHIFF, HE WON'T ALLOW IT.
THIS IS NOT A REAL
INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS A POLITICAL CIRCUS.
THERE IS NO DUE PROCESS.
THIS IS A SHOW TRIAL.
THEY HAVE PRESELECTED,
PREINTERVIEWED, IF YOU WILL COME
OF THE PEOPLE THAT THEY WANT TO
TROT OUT FIRST, THAT THEY THINK
WILL MOST MAKE THEIR CASE.
WE KNOW HE HAS INTERVIEWED HIS
FAVORITE WITNESSES BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS AND WILL NOW ONLY ALLOW
HIS FAVORITES TO TESTIFY, CHERRY
PICK THE WITNESSES.
IN FACT, THIS COMPROMISED